foreign
the three Muslims if uh if any of us
sound tired or look tired bro it's
because y'all don't know what has
happened in the last 24 hours
subhanallah but we still made it
how's it going to Gabriel
so common question we get today you know
I'm just gonna go right into it is why
do men need to marry multiple wives why
do men have to marry multiple wives and
it's never a question that's most
commonly asked by men it's one that's
most commonly asked by sisters so what
are some of the reasons that you think
women ask this and don't see eye to eye
with men
um
let's start this a bit different what do
you guys think
I love it
to the right first oh well I mean what
do we mean when we say need no one needs
to marry anyone right but if you're
looking at it from an Islamic
perspective and a lot of guys need to
need to marry to uh protect themselves
sisters need their marriage to protect
themselves why do men need to marry
multiple wives any I don't in my opinion
I don't think it's a matter of needing
to maybe some men just really have a
super high libido
um but mainly it comes down to are they
able to as far as I know if they're able
to be just between their wives they're
able to take care of all of them to a
the same degree in a fair degree then
they are allowed to do it and if they're
not able to
if they don't have that capability then
they shouldn't marry so a lot of assists
ask and I think they're also asking from
a very uh feminine perspective which
obviously saw me Allah bless them but
they probably look at it uh you know in
the way that they love men you know or
one man go into the so a lot of the time
man actually we're just talking about
this
a woman you know if she loves her man
she will only love her man even if you
look at like the most most rich or
famous guy if she's like head over heels
for her man she will not care about
anyone else she will not look at anybody
else but a guy can wholeheartedly love
his wife to death take a bullet for her
die for her one day but still at least
at this stage be attracted to other
women and then later on if you were to
get married again he could fully be
capable of loving both
mm-hmm and at the end of the day bro
like this is not just some red pill
nonsense or anything like this it's
firmly rude in Quran and Sona the proof
is Allah has made it impossible for a
woman to simultaneously be with two men
at the same time not like in an instant
but married to two men at the same time
it's impossible bro but Allah has made
it possible and allowed and legal and
permissible for its men to be you know
married to more than one woman at the
same time so if you look at that it's
it's almost like what makes no mistakes
so why would Allah allow this because
Allah knows that if a man is married to
multiple women at the same time he could
make it happen but for a woman it's not
really possible bro
oh yeah
all right so I actually got a my part is
a lot to unpack
um but for y'all y'all definitely know
like in the beginning when I first came
to Islam
I was all about for
I was all about it but I hate to say it
was more so like my nuts I just wanted
to fulfill that
um so please I I bring this to the table
because I want to hear what you have to
say considering that you live this
lifestyle right
um I may Allah bless you for a living
um but you know the more that I've been
in Islam the more I realize you know I
shouldn't be doing things based on my
naps but more so for the sake of Allah
and um
I'm under the impression now that
it's if if Allah guides you to marry one
then you marry one for Allah guys you to
marry multiple then you marry multiple
of a lot of guys you to marry none then
you marry none but it all has to be
under the guidance of Allah and not
under
um your own for your own sake you know
like you wouldn't marry a woman let's
say let's say you have one wife right
she takes care of everything for you but
there's another woman who let's say
she's younger she looks better and the
only real thing that she's bringing is
just
oh
I like in my opinion in my view in my
mindset I see this as okay
I'm gonna praise the heart on it but
Allah is probably gonna guide me in a
different direction like maybe if it's
let's say a woman who's
um she was married she got divorced she
has multiple kids she's older
and she needs a spouse and I pray about
that like it would make sense if Allah
guided me in that direction
um but again this is where I would like
to
see what you have to say on this no what
do you think about that
type I think we're saying different
things a lot of it is
correct
like obviously in the first and foremost
it's about intention
everything should be done for the sake
of Allah actually even fulfilling our
needs as the prophet saws
were a bit shocked they said you mean
that when we have intimacy we get
rewarded he said wouldn't you be
punished if you're doing Haram
it's very deep
some people think now it's taboo sex
intimacy
but it's not in the end everything you
do it for the sake of Allah is foreign
and definitely depends on the man
depends on the circumstances and
I think the question is why do men need
why do why do men want other wives in
the first because women like
they really can't see eye to eye with a
lot of that you know I I think not all
the women I think a lot of women a lot
of women yeah they usually see it after
having experienced life a bit more
gotten out of the whole deception of uh
Romeo and Juliet I was also going to say
like a lot of women in the west that
have been westernized they they've been
programmed by this whole one woman man
narrative but even that's now
see with with conditioning and
propaganda it's like one thing works
then it's like it loses it's not trendy
anymore you know you have like polyamory
which is huge in the west it's not
polishing they rebranded it right they
rebranded it but it's there it's the
same thing
well the same thing but one man multiple
women yeah no one woman multiple men no
polyamory goes the other way as well one
man two women and so on but there's a
lot like three summing and all kinds of
stuff and of course you have the Mormon
version of uh of polygamy and that's
again you know what they call Sister
Wives and they I think in early 2000s
they used to have these reality shows
about that so it was already trending
bottom line is actually is that
they always things are always changed
like right now it used to be one man one
woman the women are very into that
they're not seeing eye to eye with men
why are men looking other women why men
desire other women
now it's like women want more men
right it's almost every turning the
tables
or they don't care
or whatever all kinds of weird Trends
have it's not anymore about the whole
Romeo and Juliet romance yes there's
still women out there Wanda but we can
see a change
so
bottom line I think it needs to go back
to the the fitra how Allah created men
and women differently
I think that's where we'll find our
what's the what's the federal Defender
the natural disposition that human
beings were created
you know from biology
all the way to psychology sexuality
everything
okay and
there's a lot of misconceptions around
there most of it has been focused
towards men like we know a lot about men
and we think we know a lot about women
but it's very known little very little
known about women
so there's all these generalizations
that are made just these these
statements cliche statements or slogans
women are just like that women are just
like this I think these this needs to be
explored a bit more I think it's very
premature when people say these things
but bottom line
men have been created in such a way that
as you said
they are by Nature
polygenous
by Nature not only can they have because
a woman can have multiple men if she
wants to she can't
right technically if she wants to she
can it's probably easier for her she's
getting annoy as a woman she can just go
around to this guy much easier than a
man to go to and convince for women to
be you know in the same relationship
so
it's about not whether you can it's
about whether
Allah has allowed it first and foremost
right this is what he has allowed
in and it's about
kind of like the most
possible
or best outcome out of that relation
because you have four men one woman
yeah she can do it but you know it's not
gonna work
for many many reasons when you have a
child just imagine imagine
stuff for Lani we are four husbands of
the same woman
I mean just that thought already man
we're ready
[Music]
it doesn't work you know what I mean
I imagine she's pregnant
okay fine there's the ways to find out
player so for nine months let's say it's
your baby
are you gonna allow me to go to her
and you know oh I was like come on man
it's like no it's not just about her
anymore it's about your child being in
there
I'm work man
doesn't work but let's say you have
three wives four wives one gets pregnant
is the insurance opportunity see the
insurance opportunity you need one man
there's no scenario can you assure that
like for example a lot of people don't
know this right so for women when they
give birth they know that this is my
child you you can't a woman cannot give
birth to a child and then Wonder Isn't
mine like it's coming out of her exactly
50 genetics you know it's coming out of
her womb it's hers she raised it for
nine months it's hers right but then for
a man yes he you know ideally it's mine
you know she's my wife ideally she's not
cheating and all this but he'll never be
able to guarantee that it's it's almost
a subconscious thing you know today
there's always paternity test and all
this stuff of course but intrinsically
there's no way for him to guarantee that
so if you add like even if it's just his
own wife monogamy-wise right he can't
guarantee that because it didn't come
out of him it came out of her anyone
could have knocked her up but you had
three more men into the mixture bro
there's no way that she he can guarantee
you know which one's my child but if you
have one man what's for what for women
he can guarantee you know if he's
pregnant at all of them he knows it's
his child and each of the women gave
birth so they know it's their child too
and just think about it like this
um for women they want one specific man
that's like the proper man like
that that like high value man right if
you have four men in the equation one of
them is going to Rise Above the Rest the
one that rises above the rest that's the
one that the woman is gonna feel like
imprinted with spend the most time with
give the most attention to impregnated
by and get impregnated by because she's
obviously gonna engage more
it is intimacy right so it just doesn't
make sense when it's woman like one
woman with multiple men you know but
when we try to
understand these the wisdom again we go
back number one as Muslims that Allah
has made the rule and Allah like that
when Allah has made something like that
and we're usually addressing Muslims I
mean we'll explain to Anonymous as well
but Allah when Allah decides something
there's no
people can't just argue about it and
yeah you said a lot of women they'll say
stuff like I can't accept this
this is the wrong interpretation
anything like that a lot of women say
like
okay I agree but I agree that this is
the verse but I can't accept it I was
just going to say a lot of women
propagate that oh I could see the wisdom
1400 years ago I could see the wisdom
900 years ago is it necessary now
nowhere is in Islam doesn't say it's
only for a specific time period right
historically speaking I think there's
always been more men than women more men
die in battle more men die from disease
more men die from suicide this is
Undisputed unrefuted so when you look at
women today there's always going to be a
little bit more women for men and that's
the thing like why like in the west it's
happening anyway bro like you look at
men you know they have a work wife
normal wife they have a girlfriend you
know texting buddy you know they have
one at the gym they have what they're
cheating with this is and I'm not saying
this is okay I'm saying this is this is
happening anyway to a lot of men where
you see in Islam this is not happening
we have to take responsibility and
accountability over these women we have
to provide for them we have to you know
make sure they're taken care of their
needs are met their rights are met
they're fulfilled
let's see what the problem is bro yeah
you don't see Apartments because you're
a man they'll say all right obviously
from their perspective they look at it
from a different way but that's the
point of
that I'm making is that a Muslim has to
submit that's what Islam means
submission
I mean we could debate it trust me if
you would bring a couple educated women
here don't debate they'll say hello we
have also sexual needs and we would like
more than one man as well
because you know usually the arguments
that are made in
favorite polygyny from a man's
perspective will say oh we're different
not that we're different we'll say well
men are more sexual and they need uh
different right girl be like yeah but I
want like this kind of guy and that kind
of guy like not women are doing that
they're choosing not just one guy that
they like but they have multiple guys
they're like and that's a fact
and women are going to put up a an
argument against almost all our points
trust me even though issue of preparing
like whatever I can control myself maybe
I don't even want to have children I
just want to have them met right so all
these when you look at the Quran Sunnah
is there really a justification for
pillaging that is there a rational
justification
I haven't seen
where like oh because the man wants more
women or because he's more sexual or he
just got higher libido man some women
are have a lot more libido than I think
I think I think where it stems from is
in Islam even in Surah on the side
specifically talks about you know
lineage like we know that Allah really
honors lineage and lineage is something
extremely honored and that I would say
is a great you know because Bro think
about it like because I know you're
saying like women can argue that okay
what if I have multiple husbands and we
don't have kids okay but anytime you you
sign the marriage contract you get
married there's a possibility and you
tell me you have intimacy that you could
have kids I don't care if you're double
strapped up condom or whatever like you
could still technically have kids yeah
and the thing is you cannot you that the
Assurance or paternity that lineage is
completely nullified as soon as you add
more than one man to the mix
but the other way around it's not do you
get what I mean so in a rational
argument so that's a point that I want
to agree with that from a rational
perspective but everything else in terms
of like sex and drive and man are this
and that I I don't think so if you're
not human sexuality that's a big debate
man you could argue that women need it
women today or they can be with multiple
men at the same exactly so again it goes
back to Allah's rule his decree what he
wants us to to do and sometimes we know
there's a wisdom that's described and
sometimes there isn't and that's the
whole point of submission
so putting aside that that Allah has
said so then we can discuss other issues
right as to why and how and you also saw
this last episode you said that just
because something is there that I don't
agree with doesn't mean it's not the
truth yeah meaning if something could be
true and you could necessarily just not
agree with it but it doesn't make it not
the truth you know what I mean yeah
right we're not gonna we're not like you
know liberals whose truth are we talking
about none of that bro uh Romney
what are your thoughts bro I see you
real like yeah I see your gears working
there yeah I'm just thinking back to my
uh my class at I3 and learning about uh
like also and
um like you one of the things they
talked about is taking the hikma and
making it like in Allah taking the
wisdom behind something or the perceived
wisdom like you could say oh though the
wisdom behind Salah is it it gives you
peace of mind and right that's true but
there's Allah say that right and can you
take any statement as an illah and make
a ruling based off that because let's
say that people were to take us
busy with my brother uh Gabriel was
saying that you know it's because of a
high sex drive well if you take that as
an illah and then you could say a woman
has a high sex drive would you be you
know then be able to apply to a woman I
see I see it from that perspective 100
no doubt but um so now the question is
so why do men do it anyway so let's say
okay there's a theory we always say
there's a theory and what you do and
that's the argument the women like okay
we can see the theory
why do you guys do it like we don't have
to do it it's like it's a fart or
something even though some scholarship
that's the default because I starts with
two three and four
so
but again the argument would be like oh
why do you guys have to you don't really
have to do it it hurts us and so on like
it's not applicable in today's society
there's certain issues why don't you
let's address this fact too for the
sisters that are watching that yeah it's
not like the fact that women get jealous
and extremely you know let's see it does
bother them it's not something that's
new or something that men don't realize
or something that Allah doesn't realize
is stuck for Allah you look at you know
the wives of the Prophet Islam right A
lot of them had jealousy bro did they
not
there's narrations that she would still
be jealous and she wasn't even alive bro
you know like that how is that rational
you know so you look at that it's not
something that we dismiss whatsoever
it's just something it's like at the at
some point you have to forego what you
want versus what Allah wants and there's
no there's no compulsion in Dean
obviously right but at the end of that
that the end of the day Islam is
submission right you you have a say okay
cool but how much can you really do
sometimes let's say you're tired you
don't want to wake up for pressure bro
but you still know you got to wake up
bro yeah let me slide in let me
piggyback on this because I think that's
very important I think it's first and
foremost like why do men do this just
answer the question or you have the men
that do it further enough and you have
the men that do it physically like for
the sake of Allah right now
how can you do something truly for the
sake of Allah well you have to be close
to Allah how can you praise and receive
direct guidance and know that this is
the sign from Allah that Allah has like
you have no question in your mind like
this is it this is the sign and and you
know it to be designed therefore you
fully submit to that son you would only
know that if you're close to Allah so it
was like
for men it's like if they even want to
consider this an opportunity or an
option like they have to get close with
Allah
yeah
one small point I also want to add in is
I think we're the outliers in terms of
the societies and civilizations and the
time periods I think we're the outliers
most from what I hear most civilizations
of the past were polygenous yes uh to
some extent and I think maybe the Romans
were the ones that had this kind of
strict monogamy but um even they had
like doing all kinds of weird yeah yeah
stuff a lot of them look the question I
mean it's good what you said you've said
doing it for the sake of Allah and doing
it for you enough
let's analyze those two points I think
the great points
doing it for the sake of Allah what does
that mean so of course you're trying to
have Chastity and protect yourself for
the sake of Allah because you don't want
to do something Haram that's one of the
main intentions right let's say
you marry a widow
right I mean these days especially who
wants to marry with him stuff
so you kind of say you know what I'm
gonna just take care of this woman
because she's alone so do you see the
intention is for example or divorcee
right she's not exactly what society
would consider marriage material Prime
but you're saying you know for the sake
of Allah I'm going to marry her she's
alone whatever you know we don't want
our sister to be alone her husband died
whatever's divorced problems
so you're doing it for sick of Allah
it's good rewarded Allah bless you
you're protecting Society actually
people think is just personal
no you got to take care of society
because Society will corrupt you
if Society is Imagine just a bunch of
women running around 10 years not
married three years I mean come on bro
how can a woman stay without a man for
like more than two three years
forget more than a few months stuff
you think that's the misconception
imagine the women have no desire they
don't start thinking they don't start
fantasizing they don't start
looking
they do
it's the reality Manner and roughly you
know there's not there they do so now
imagine you have a bunch of women not
married
divorce whatever without running around
the society two three years without no
man
just from a sexual perspective
just from that point forget about
everything else being taken care of
having someone to love easy to follow
it's easy to slip bro bro come on what's
gonna happen
so Islam gives a solution so it's for
the sake of Allah to protect yourself
and to protect your Society
um right
so that woman that you're talking about
that that woman that you know has no man
she slips she can't slip by herself
right there's another person involved in
the center too so just slippery slope
right so like there's there's an
objective here and no one can argue that
this is wrong and usually it's men who
leave women
so women are alone because someone left
them or used them or whatever
it's like that who I mean mortality
rates are higher in men usually
due to war due to many things so it's
again woman is left alone
like you know we look at them sahaba
I mean so many women were left alone but
would they just stay as soon as that's
done pretty much oh we'll get married
man are you talking about three months
within three months three you know
menstrual circles we get they'll get
married
none of that like no I'm gonna stay
another two years three years let's see
five ten years some women are alone
just get married and we can talk about
why women are not getting married today
but that's the reality on the other side
desire
right there's nothing wrong
if you take your desire out in halal if
you want to marry a woman who's
extremely beautiful attractive and
that's your purpose again because you
want to I mean you could do it in horror
much easier
probably get you know is faster easier
you can go and pick different ones if
you want whatever much easier
but you're choosing to do it in Allah
says like the difference between Haram
is literally like Nika you know just two
witnesses Mahar and let me give let me
give another rational you know
propagation aside from just Assurance of
lineage but you look at the ummah any
type of Deen any type of of team that
you're trying to grow right from a
strictly population point of view right
how difficult is it to just have
monogamy and grow in ummah compared to
having polygeny Brothers if you have one
woman and you knock her up she's out of
commission for nine months ten months
sometimes even more with complications
right and sure forget her forget her
body but her her whole physiology her
whole biochemistry can't even snap back
into just having another kid for like a
long time bro so you're looking at you
know a couple years Max just to like you
know have a few kids maybe five to ten
years to have like I don't know three
four or five kids plus if that's what
you want right for strictly those people
but if you have multiple wives it's
easier on them they can help one another
out you know you could have four you
know kids per year that's insane bro
subhanallah and I think from Strictly
just growing the Oma point of view
people don't accept that bro people they
won't right in the process and we have
deleted like processing said I will be
taking pride in the numbers
of my um
what does that mean this is encouraging
procreation today we're like no uh I
don't know like come on let's be honest
bro everyone is we're worried about
having children condoms contraceptives
so many things people are just okay sex
is for enjoyment no doubt and desire
but it's also what you said and most
people
are very carefully so the whole you know
Family Planning let's see
I mean I've lived in Arabia and I've
seen where people
yeah they're maybe not as rich or having
you know they speak advance in car and
mortgage and whatnot but I got five six
ten kids they're happy man
they're happy Allah provides Allah says
we take care of you don't worry but we
don't believe this stuff and that's the
problem look around not honestly do we
really believe in the words of Allah and
his messenger or do we believe in those
that are easy for us
I don't know I don't see it
Moon
I think it comes back to the walkwood
right like not just for the men but for
the woman right so women they have this
problem with men uh even the idea of
them marrying multiple women I was about
to say multiple men and stuff for a lot
so if the woman is seeing you in their
perspective then she's being controlled
by her nuts because her desires is that
she only wants to be with that man right
she wants him to herself this is a
problem and then it's also another
problem where you have a guy who his
fitra like his internal state is wanting
to be with multiple women and I'm not
saying that every guy should be more to
a woman I'm saying like Okay what if
what if you are a Muslim man you are
married right you love your wife but you
pray and Allah sends you direct guidance
to now marry this woman
made this divorcey but instead of uh
fearing Allah you feel your wife because
she's saying no I'm Gonna Leave You if
you marry another woman that's what
happened it's like well I mean do you
want me to go against Allah's guidance
like is that what I'm hearing you know
and this is where again like tawaku has
to be important for both the man and the
woman yeah whether it gets Broad and
bound back to what to desire oh you just
want to satisfy your desire am I not
good enough for you these kind of
replies
I mean we don't think from that
perspective even the most humble men if
he even dares to bring up this topic
he'll be crucified recrucified in a
second like oh
you want to satisfy your desires so what
obviously like wait a second if you're a
Muslim or a Muslim man
because the man have an issue with it
too today
it's not just women oh that's a funny
thing like men are against polygeny too
even though secret they all desire right
so there's a huge thing on Bengali too
so I don't know you know I can only
speak about Bengali communities and they
see communities but I'm sure other you
know cultures can relate but there's a
huge taboo and vilification against
polygyny in the Bengali community
even men even men I'm that's what I'm
talking about like bro subhanallah men
today and families today are stuck for
all I'm not generalizing but I've seen
you know many they'd rather their their
daughter becomes a prostitute today than
be a second wife wives are saying I've
heard this so many times let him go to a
prostitute when he needs to but no
marriage
the Arabs are famous on this Arab women
like it's no joke I'm not making this up
and people are watching and they're in
you know they know what I'm talking
about
so why is because we can't accept what
Allah has to create
right I mean imagine
I mean here we we look at Allah's decree
and Rule versus also fitra because it is
to make that argument
let's flip the script
imagine women are allowed to marry more
than one man
you think many would take that on they
would do it
let's say we are like you know like like
men
are just the law of Allah you think is
permissible
it goes against fitter though that's
when it goes against biology it goes
against anything right so there's but
you know a lot of women are saying that
oh imagine if we were to be allowed to
how would you feel like what what type
of argument I don't think that's uh if
you look at this even if today women
don't agree men but they know men cheat
they know men I mean you're a lot you're
you're okay with him to go to prostitute
you're okay knowing that he's watching
porn he's cheating on you watching porn
man I feel like they know emotionally
there's no emotions you're safe and
thinking I'm okay he's mine yeah that's
what it is see and then they are giving
the argument well imagine that we'll
flip the tables and we would be able out
to marry how would you feel right they
make that car no because probably would
be smashing each other but we'll be
killing each other yeah women even
though they don't agree even though
whatever in the end
some will just allow it some will just
close their eyes someone just allow it
in the Haram sense the problem is here
not with
them with knowing the fitra of men and
the manner by Nature pledges
is that they are not accepting the rule
of Allah
because we can make a bunch of arguments
back and forth flip the tables
possibilities you know theoretical
philosophical arguments in the end this
is what it goes down to Allah created
some certain way we can do it they
cannot not to mention they won't even if
they would be allowed to they can do
successfully you know they'll fail
within the first it'll be chaos as you
said he'll be like man Massacre right
and
it's just it's not possible the lineage
the procreation there's so many things
but in the end our psychologists don't
it wouldn't work
and it works this way
that men are polygenists
the problem is both men and women are
not willing to submit to Allah does
everyone have to be religious no
is that like okay now everyone has to do
it there's a lot of women for every
month no but
we shouldn't if it happens shouldn't
and it's sad that today people are
trying to justify islamically and
whatnot
but
looking at reality I would say it would
solve a lot of problems in the society a
lot of problems and that's
that's facts I'm glad that you said that
because it's more so an issue of today
because bro like the older generation
women like it's almost like they just
understand oh they're all right with it
oh yeah bro like even as a non-muslim my
grandma
what she's going through but every time
she asks me like I'm doing and she asked
me like if I have any girlfriend she
doesn't ask like oh do you have a
girlfriend she's like oh how many
girlfriends do you have now you know
like she's always asking multiple when I
tell her like if I'm talking to one
she's like what are you doing talking to
one like you should be talking in the
morning and this is not me justifying
I'm just saying like it's it's more so
seen in the women today you know their
feet throws are a little less corrupted
the older women you know older
Generations when you look at the Modern
even men and women both as the
generations go on we get more it's
possible to have a successful model 100
I mean sorry
again people are going to get upset but
let's look at
a current phenomenon
the Mormons
yeah they have a lot of issues but if
you analyze
just the attitude of the females yes
they'll have drama and whatnot but if
you analyze the attitude of the females
and how proud they are their religion
that their religioning encourages them
to do that
you'll be shocked
compare that to
the Muslim sisters
I know they try to make Mormons look bad
and all these Cults and whatever the guy
the priest is put that aside man this is
just propaganda in reality if you are
have you ever talked to one or seen a
community
these women are proud of their religion
are they going to be jealous yes are
they going to have issues yes but bro
they're proud why do they do it they
don't do it because oh yeah Russian
arguments it's like they'll tell it's in
the Bible
and want to bring back this the
Christian African sisters I look I
watched an interview because a debate
between a Christian sister African
sister and a Muslim sister both ugandans
and all the Muslim girls back no I don't
accept it I don't like it I don't feel
good about it and the Christian almost
just just refuting I was like no but men
are gonna do this but no the reality is
that he's no but he is a king and that's
what it is it's always been like our
ancestors have done it you're ashamed of
your ancestry like her arguments were
just on point and here the Muslim
is you know it's in our Sharia and here
the the non-muslim You could argue that
in today's context even they believe
it's not part of kashank has been
abrogated by the New Testament
right but no she's saying no just so
it's shocking to India what is it about
it's about what does Allah say you know
and is it in line I mean are we aligning
our fitra
according to that because then that's
when Society
succeeds this whole one for one in the
end okay this is the default today laws
are around that and so on but look at
Society why are we not fixing the
problems when it comes to families
families broken the first fear of a
woman and a man when it comes to
religion oh family's gonna be broken
your home wrecker you're this you're
that look at monogamous couples like man
it's like disasters
divorce rates are huge because in the
end it's not about religion it's not
about among me it's about what did Allah
allow permit and is it a solution for
for problems that we have today and I
would argue it's a huge solution for
problems that have to especially with
high divorce rates especially with men
dying much earlier especially with
forget forget about that we're talking
about quality of Men available man you
know we're not talking about here let's
oh but there's enough men for no no wait
a second
proper men
quality of men who can really qualify to
be husbands how many do we have in this
world
you know they have this thing in the
west that 80 of women sleep with 20 of
men
I know you do the math that's four to
one
yeah I would say I would probably argue
it's even less than twenty percent
right because again where what's their
qualification are they real men
can they hold the family together it's
not just about having sex bro
we're talking we're talking here about
marriage our people enough are people
forgetting that we're not talking about
dating him
oh what's what do you feel your desires
no it's we're like we're talking about
marriage running a family holding a
household holding responsibility
how many men can do that monogamous or
polygamous
very few and then you have sisters who
are they walking they wake up man I'm
telling you and that's another
proof that the fitra will kick in But
first you got to be slapped a few times
around by life
then you wake up and you're like
you know what women say man they say I'd
rather be with you and share you with a
hundred women than be with some
you know who who can't handle Lily like
to like I'd rather share it with 100.
than to be with one guy who's not able
to do anything
so some women wake up and they realize
it
so I do want to ask a bit about the
issues that it solves but before that I
want to touch on a point that you
mentioned earlier uh because it really
reminded me of two hours from the Quran
subhanallah uh in in regards to you know
our choice if we have a choice and all
that so there's a very beautiful verse
where Allah he says in the Quran it does
not befitting for a believing man or
woman
when Allah and his messenger decide in a
matter or when the Messenger will also
decides in a matter that they should
have any choice in it right he also says
that it's not befitting for a believing
man or a woman or um
um oh they will not truly believe they
will not fully believe until they won
three qualifications one they made the
prophet saws a judge between them and
any of their disputes so let's say we're
disputing
he saw that already right yes two they
find no ill feeling or discontentment in
their hearts that's very important with
the verdict and three they submit in
full submission
because it's not about like yeah I
accept and she's just sitting there like
ah cause it's gonna you're gonna explode
at some point you can do some
it's about really
allowing the Iman to penetrate the heart
and you're like no this is what Allah is
it's not just like yeah I believe in it
but you know no I believe in it I submit
to it this is the best thing for not
only him as a husband but for me as a
wife yeah so let's talk a little bit
about that what does that mean for it to
actually be beneficial and save
relationships and then solve these
problems well you have obviously the
problem of women being single
you see women
yeah this poor quality of women today no
doubt about it they've been attacked
been targeted by Society
but in the end
who allowed it
you know we are in charge the men are in
charge we keep bragging about it yeah
we're in charge got one okay
so then
we we have to admit that we have failed
and we allowed for these
feminist
to indoctrinate our women
imagine you're in a in a fight yeah
you're in a you know the ring
and you're being punched and you're
being attacked and you just back down
back down what's gonna happen you're
gonna get smashed because all you do is
back down you don't punch back you don't
fight back that's what men have done it
doesn't matter how strong you are
like we haven't fought back there's no
strong resistance to this huge movement
that has destroyed our society feminism
on feminism on that platform on that you
know it was lgbtq that moved on
I mean if you feel this this was
influence lgbtq was influenced as soon
as pedophilia or it already is and
that's why one of the sisters said
he said why do you think the first
letter is l
in the lgbtq because women are at the
front
you know women are at the front
so
but who allowed them man we didn't fight
back now you have red pill
that's I mean it's
not that old
but in general like this whole movement
has started many many decades ago
and look around what's it what it's done
look around so we men are responsible
so women are doing their thing the
question is what are we doing
as men we could take care of this
problem single women we could take care
of the problem of divorced women we
could take care of the problem of
of of widows we can take care of the
problems of Orphans
we can take care of these issues
but we don't it solves a lot of problems
I mean why do men have to go and cheat
why are they strip clubs why are they
porn shops
sex all these things men don't feel like
they're satisfied bro why are there
literally islands with kids bro what
they're doing today bro have you not
seen the one that takes his nuffs as is
God yeah right so that's that's the most
important part where we live in a
society where it's all about having a
few you should be happy you should feel
good you know your life should be the
best life for you okay everything should
be good for you but it's like no it's
it's all for the sake of Allah like even
if you're suffering you should be very
content if you're doing it for the sake
of Allah yeah you know and like that's
the most important part is having men
come back to that having women come back
to that because um that's what will
inevitably bring
Islam back to its core you know yeah
like that's what we'll bring the Uma
back together of course there's other
factors I'll get the drift yeah yeah and
I think that's a really really good
segue for what I wanted to talk about
which is it's crazy because the topic of
polygyny Almost Doesn't start with the
the topic of polygeny it's something
that's so deeply rooted uh there's a
verse in the Quran imagine if people had
this mentality I can't remember exactly
so correct me if I'm wrong but it's
something basically one of the prophets
I think was saying that um my living my
dying My Sacrifice everything
the lord of the worlds everything that
exists the owner of everything that
exists upon Allah and now people you
know you know my my everything is for me
my enough my desires my pleasure and so
on and so forth so it's it like again it
doesn't start with the talking of
politician that's why it's so hard to
talk about it because it's something
that's so deeply rooted what's your
belief what's your Akita you know I'm
not trying to men how to check anybody
but
um you know Manchester attacking people
here unfortunately but like it's it's
what is your purpose why are you here
where do you get immorality from because
if they're not getting this is something
that people don't understand you are
taught if you're not taught Islam you're
taught liberalism you taught secularism
you're you're taught capitalism you're
taught these things growing up and if
you think that this is just the natural
state of a human being you're wrong this
is the natural state of the human being
growing up in the western Society if you
were to go back 1400 years ago you'd be
so different spent a lot you if you're a
woman
oh yeah yeah you going back years ago
you'd probably be pilchinist if you're a
woman or if you're a man you'd be
pluginous
just a few hundred years ago what
happened like what was it the 1600s what
were white people saying about slavery
and everything that was the norm
that was there was even a black man who
owned black slaves yes subhanallah
what's his name
you know there's more than that not just
one you were seeing that in the in the
stand-up comedy or something like that
you're watching something together
there's a black man that that uh yeah
anyway I mean that's so true yeah this
is what
this is what uh is the at the core of
the problem now we can discuss how it
works how it can work how sisters can
devise different strategies to cope with
it
but if this is not right and this is not
right I think one of the most valuable
things you said a few episodes ago bro
was Islam Today is operating in a
non-muslim framework and I think you
were saying the same thing
like what is he what does Gabriel mean
by that it's like Islam should operate
in Islamic framework with Sharia and
everything Islam Today is operating in
Western framework Western Law so you
look here and you want to practice Islam
you want to have multiple wives bro in
some countries including the one we're
at right now Canada it's actually
illegal for a man to marry more than one
woman bro
so you want to practice Islam or do you
want to break the law with severe fines
and imprisonment I'm talking like the
whole nine yards bro
but in Canada it's not illegal to cheat
on your woman bro
I want you guys to just hear what I said
it's illegal to have a second wife in
Canada but it's elite but it's not
illegal to cheat on your wife to have a
mistress to have a sad thing to go to an
escort it's not
no this is Western Law so how much can
you really Implement Islam in a
non-muslim framework it's not going to
happen bro
down calm down bro and I want to just
like add in here
because you've said this multiple times
it's not just in previous episodes that
we recorded but like I'm talking about
like a year ago we were doing like
intimacy intimacy Siri and you were
saying that like in Islam
um it's truly about submission the
longer you are a Muslim the more you
realize like if
you have to submit you know like you you
may not submit now but at some point or
another you're going to submit and like
think about think about this right you
have the woman she doesn't want to
submit to the fact that okay Allah has
decreed this and it would actually be
very beneficial and if Allah guys the
man to do so then she should be more
than on board with it and then you have
the man who doesn't want to submit and
the fact that okay Allah maybe has given
him this guidance but because he fuses
woman he doesn't want his woman to leave
him then
you know he's not submitting he's not
submitting to the will of Allah it's a
good price man I wish we could talk
forever bro this is a very good it is it
is inshallah anything else to wrap up
closing thoughts
there's a lot to be discussed obviously
today we're covered
the tip of the iceberg yeah I mean we
would like to go into like how it can
happen like we talked about the theory
now what are the arguments from a Dean
perspective why people should accept
that we could we should also give
successful stories and models that it
can work there's definitely going to be
unsuccessful as well we can mention
those as well but we can talk about how
because a lot of people are looking into
it today bro huh you gotta leave soon
bro I know
you know just in the future yeah
this is what's going to happen
inshallah go ahead bro
it's three minutes three minutes if you
can give something in three minutes why
not
well look bottom line is that it works
it's not easy
it works it's uh it's a challenge but it
works it makes you grow as a man
a lot of people thought we'll be against
you we'll tell you stop many people stop
many people wrong other people for do
from by doing that like it's not about
just like you get this idea this
romantic idea let me just do it it's
really a
something that's commitment commitment
yeah
maturity
it teaches you a lot about yourself
yeah we can sit on the member and preach
about everything and defend the prophet
saws
did it if he felt or he knew from Allah
that somehow he's going to destroy women
or it's going to hurt them he didn't
want to hurt he said I'm the best to my
my wives to my family the best amongst
you are the bestest family and I am the
best to my family that's what he said
yeah where the wives jealous yes in the
end it works it worked then it works
today to work tomorrow it will solve a
lot of problems they are models there's
brothers who have done it
but bottom line is
both have to submit to Allah both
have to fully submit Allah it becomes
easier
it's never going to be perfect this
dunya's not gender
it's all good but in reality it works
and um
I think more I I think more people
should do it I encourage people because
it's going to solve a lot of problems in
this ummah I think that's a wonderful
point to end it on inshallah if you guys
mean this far smash the like button more
episodes coming inshallah an actual
practical implications and applications
of polygyny but for this little you know
teaser inshallah all right and with that
being said
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]